[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we ask the question well we
are actually gonna be asked lots of
questions
it's an AMA episode y'all asked me and
Rhett anything anything anything at all
of course yeah you know the illusion of
an AMA is that well you can ask anything
but that doesn't mean we're gonna answer
it's not answer me at everything
that would be an aim know how you spell
aim but okay Tommy it's I'm a so we're
so we got lots of questions here but we
do want to let you know we're gonna get
into them this is the last actually the
second to last ear biscuit of 2018 it's
something very exciting is happening and
happening in 2019 for those of you who
enjoy your biscuits visually you've
enjoyed it a number of places on this is
mythical channel now the GMM channel and
in an effort to continue to confuse you
and mix things up we're going to be
putting all the ear biscuits the past
ear biscuits and the president ear
biscuits and the future your biscuits on
its own You Tube channel youtube.com
slash ear biscuits whoa whoa whoa what
ask me anything not get why you got to
get that loud about asking me anything
it's not about youtube.com slash ear
biscuits why do you need to get that
loud about it because that's what you
have to do I've been on the internet for
a long time in any time a youtuber has
an announcement they've got to get
really enthusiastic about it right you
know what I'm saying you got to get
excited about it you have to make it so
normally you're excited so they get
excited go over there and describe it I
mean subscribe it subscribe to it you
can describe it you slash ear biscuits
past present future starting in the new
year starting in the new year that will
that's where you all your new biscuits
will be housed so we're not in the new
year yet we're in the now year you can
subscribe now though you said that ask
me anything
how do you subscribe you go to
youtube.com slash your biscuits and
click on that subscribe button you could
probably also program your computer to
automatically you could write a script
okay I'm over a now what do we want to
describe out you can actually go into a
public library and write a script on all
the computers and get them all to
subscribe to it too now that I encourage
that so before we get to the first
question but I'll give you a cookie I
guess I have a question for us because
we didn't get to settle the conversation
we were having right before we came in
here cuz it's like alright you're like
what are you cold no I have on a coat
were you cold I anticipated the
potential of being cold it's that time
of year man you got to bundle up I like
this jacket
I got fur around it but it's interesting
that we're both comfortable right now
and this thing I ain't a short sleeve
shirt your isn't that a beautiful pair
you're in like a nice and big jacket
it's both comfortable isn't it beautiful
that we can both be comfortable and not
have to worry about what the other
person is wearing but I'm concerned
about one of us and I don't know who I'm
supposed to be concerned about it I
think one of us may be getting sick I'm
probably just getting hot okay before we
get in other people's questions my
question is can we settle the
conversation that we were having right
before this I don't know if I need to
settle it I just which was I was just
pointing we were coming we were coming
in here and then it was like well I hold
on I gotta I gotta go pee before we
start and then you're like oh me too and
we go out there and there's two
bathrooms and there the doors are shut
on both of them and I'm in front of you
and from my perspective I did what I
always do cuz I'm a I know how to do
things
oh gosh I knocked on the door and
immediately grabbed the head and then I
grabbed no hesitation there was no
listening and when I heard the thing
when I saw no there was no listening
because my ears were closed
I witnessed you doing it and I know your
reaction time is not on the fast side
and so the fact the fact that you not
immediately lower the hand to the handle
made me realize that you are the person
in this office who does the one-two
combo and makes everyone else nervous
maybe there's other people that do it
all I know is this
oh you experience is that inside of
there I do
like the unsettling feeling of someone
grabbing the handle of a bathroom door
while I'm doing my business I mean I
will just pucker right up and everything
stops for a moment because it's because
it's nerve-racking you feel like
somebody's coming in the door well I I
guess I don't agree with that so part of
so my technique well is to knock on the
door and listen and give people an
adequate time to respond which I would
say is 2 seconds not 0.2 seconds and
then I would say 95 to 98% of the
occupants in this office will respond
with some sort of audible indication
that they're in there all right listen
in all my years of working here I've
never had to grab the handle not once
that's not that can't be true because
you know what some a lot of times the
door shut and there's nobody in there so
you knock and then you have to grab the
handle and the door opens well no I'm
saying when I didn't hear anything after
a certain amount of time I was just like
nobody's in there I'm saying I haven't
ever grab the handle and had it locked
on me I'm not I didn't hear any not
immediately grab the handle immediately
it if I owe you know what it could have
been the two hands you could have
knocked with one hand and grabbed with
the other hand it almost sounded similar
undermining see if you change this I
possibly could have been two hand in it
how quickly that was just how quickly
that's patently false it was this quick
it was okay I'm gonna make a the noise
of the handle in my mouth it was well no
it wasn't I think I think what happened
with that quick I grabbed the handle but
I didn't push I was ready I had my hand
over it it was almost a hover and you
misinterpreted that as a I've been on
the receiving end of it many times is
what I'm saying I've been in there I've
been midstream and I hear a knock and I
can't immediately I say my word is yep
because I know the question is is there
someone in there so I just go ahead and
answer I don't say occupied that sounds
like some sort of Victorian thing
I just say yep I think we've but I am
having flashbacks to this particular
part of conversation I think you did
convince me to change from occupied to
yep
I'm just remember that but I always said
yeah listen nobody said anything and
you're saying it's because I did the
handle too quick but then you're saying
so after I did the hand on it's like you
don't say anything no no I'm saying if
you had if you had to give a nobody said
anything because you grabbed the handle
at that point they're just trying to get
in they're like well I guess the lock is
gonna do the my business now and then
you just shut up because you're nervous
because you think maybe something's
breaking in on you well no now I think
that the doors locked but nobody's in
there I'm just saying that happens at my
house all the time I don't know how my
kids do it but the and maybe that's what
ruined it for me
I'm just saying they'll they'll lock no
one in the bathroom and then nobody can
get I've been there before but that
happened nothing on the I'm you're
saying being on I don't know how it is
for you you don't know because no one
else does this we should have asked we
should have waited for the person to
come out and we should have asked them
about the experience
and here's another that would have
settled here's another thing it's Teddy
sometimes people don't have a new endure
this hold on prosecution I don't think
you have a leg to stand on because
sometimes the door doesn't completely
shut sometimes people forget to lock and
at that point you've got full exposure I
did knock yeah and all this in question
is how long I waited you knock and
that's a that's two open to it I feel
like it's one of those situations where
it's like a word that used to be two
words but became one word over time like
you you're knock your knocking twist is
such is one action at the moment it's a
knocking twist my response to a knock is
it's very quick it's a knocking twist
yes all one word I'm immediately ready
if somebody knocks to say yep but when
you are peeing or pooping you're focused
on that and when somebody knocks I gotta
say you got a lot of your brain is is
currently committed to just hitting the
toilet properly fine I'll knock twice
you need a second and a half to say yep
you got them i'ma knock five times from
now on it's not a number of times you
want to it's the number of times
you're not gonna be here when they say
anything it's the amount of time you
wait you got to give it three seconds
just give it three seconds cuz listen
I'll tell you what happened to me yet
this bathroom the same exact bathroom
that you knocked on I went up to the
bathroom and I knocked on and I knocked
on it and then I realized oh in fact if
I see that the door is slightly open
I still knock I'm that respectful of
somebody's private space so I knocked
and I was like oh the doors open I
pushed it open some locked the door Oh
someone who doesn't work here but works
for us in a capacity was midstream oh
wow midstream now I see why that you
have so much pain associated with this
because you've you've it's just called
respect man been hurt you've been RESP
ECT so you you you walked in on somebody
so you're very sensitive to it that was
that's not what happened that was last
year I've always been sensitive to it
because when people some people don't
knock at all and I think oh that's
horrible I'm in my mind you're knocking
twist is the same as no knock at all
it's so jarring
it might be worse because it sounds like
two people trying to get in at the same
time like this is a full-on attack I am
I'm I'm hurt to be lumped into that
category you should feel bad it's not
the same category a knocking twist is
not the same as just a phantom twist as
a victim of the knocking twist I gotta
say it's as bad as the twist maybe I
just need one good walk in and it'll
cure me I think I just gotta I gotta
walk in on somebody and what are you
saying now when people knock I think I
heard you say it the other day you
saying yep now - yeah yeah you're not
gonna change my mind about this then you
can't keep winning these I mean I'm a
walk in occupied does the job
uh-huh does the job occupy that's three
whole syllables you got it buddy you put
anything you say at all really it could
be effective
but do you say something back because
hey I I knocked earlier at the other
bathroom the the hidden poop bathroom
and I'm pretty sure that was Alex's
voice he had time to respond you don't
know what I'm telling you you you did
this you did I didn't know you did that
nah I just walked away I didn't say it
should I have said anything mister and a
set and setting of standards you do not
speak back to a person it's like yeah
it's like okay I'll be waiting right out
of here listening yeah you don't know
this is this seems self-evident to me
you do not speak back I did I just want
to make sure you didn't go and don't
apologize
I walked away now huh if you do the
knocking twist apologize but if you just
do the knock and they say yep that's it
just I walk you're right only part is
though it's called the the knocking walk
yeah
knocking walk totally accept ice I would
say slink ice linked away defeated
because I was really excited to drop a
deuce in that bathroom you got to know
at least 30 feet away and then I'm like
now am I going back to the other one
it's right beside Feldman's desk well
there's a wall a wall we installed a
wall like a little partition wall does
that do the job yeah it makes you feel
like you're not next to the bed oh great
that was the that was the design
intention you know seriously that's why
we put it there the wall made you not
even think about the fact that you're
right next to the bathroom but now you
go it's like it's a totally different
part of the office but you're like
you're like seven feet from somebody
pooping oh well this is not a complaint
session I don't I don't want you just
saying well if I am gonna complain it's
gonna be about these six things it's not
what we're we're not expanding the
conversation unless you're gonna defend
me and my knocking twist which seems
pretty indefensible
I will think I'm gonna think about it I
don't like I don't like counting seconds
in my head though
because they're always faster than they
are in practice I have to count them out
loud I would say we need to do it out
loud just remove not not one 1,000 just
remove the twist this removes them the
twist from your from your world the
twist will come naturally when you're
like oh nobody's in there and then
you'll just enter and twist is just
intrinsic to entering I've daughters had
to pee really badly
well can't blame a man for that not sure
we settled anything many times I mean we
could also Institute just the open door
policy where it's like as many people
just want to go and watch can I mean
we're all human that's the worst idea it
is again it's kind of like counting out
loud now that I've done it I'm like okay
now I know what time it is notice B so
we're not we just to clarify for legal
reasons we do not have an open door
bathroom policy and mythical
entertainment and that one guy that
walked in on the coast like the
co-founder of the company was just
talking about that for entertainment
purposes only
isn't that in the description of all of
our pocket
yeah right like the for entertainment
purpose use express herein are not
actual views they're just presented as
entertainment fodder but let's present
some quite some answers to some
questions but before we do that link you
have on a jacket that people can't buy
but you have on a shirt that people can
buy look at this it's a mythical skate
esque shirt it's a black ski task black
shirt and this has mythical on it it's
like that's I mean can't go wrong with
that go to mythical dot store wears last
time you skated on a skateboard probably
three months ago last Christmas how did
that Christy bought me one of those
trendy little skateboards and I was like
girl you don't want me to get on this
and where'd you do it on the street on
our street yeah cuz like Oh Lincoln in
Lando would like ride their scooters
around you can also get that shirt at
amazon.com slash mythical we do have
some select merchandise over there at
different stuff it does mythical you can
pop out for those of you who are like
I'm only go to do it on Amazon well you
know what we thought about you you know
what let's get into some questions we
sweat shirts too over there
let's get into some questions here
tatianna call lova
asks what questions are you tired of
being asked
hashtag here let's start with that one
of course yeah let's uh let's let's say
all the questions we're not gonna answer
I guess well I think the most common
question I get asked is why how do you
put up with that other guy or what makes
you so amazing right so tired how are
you so amazed as probably how I should
have phrased that no it's what's the
grossest thing you guys have ever eaten
on GMM that we get that question a lot
every QA and that's a fair question
because it's it's just the first one
that comes to your mind when you know I
told you this this morning I don't know
what this is not much of a realization
but sometimes you you realize things
that are obvious and it just feels like
an epiphany at least I do that all the
time
I think you just described your life I
just realized something that's been
obvious to everybody else I realized
that I can't think of another show that
unapologetically eats balls like us it's
like that's what's happened to our show
it's like Andrew I always called him
Zimmerman but that's not it cancelled
he's gone Bizarre Foods is gone it's
like you're right I mean but it wasn't
me he ate a lot of balls just eating so
much crazy stuff but nobody on the
internet and I guess we yeah we got the
corner on that now
now the Bizarre Foods is gone but the
ball in the corner corner pocket right
in the pocket to tie ball to ball into
the corner puck about pocket we mean
crotch so I don't know and then it I
think the reason why it's so annoying is
because we haven't come up with just
that answer that we say all the time I
have but then I feel the need to say
well honestly it all runs together it's
also bad because you say well congealed
pork blood is the worst thing that we've
eaten pork blood will it taco
but I don't even know it's concise and
it's not false yeah it's just it's an
answer that's it is false there's got to
be things that we mean that or that are
just that bad the bile was a
ridiculously horrible again I don't want
I don't even want to answer all right
we're answering it but the reason so
tired of answering it but we I think the
reason why we're tired of answer is
because we there's it's not a it's not a
fun or funny answer and we get it all
the time so it's the one-two punch of we
get it all the time and it's not a great
response it's kind of like telling the
story of how we met while we turn that
into a song and then it became something
that was like okay now we can keep
telling this story on the first day of
our great well the other question that
we get asked almost as much and I
actually think it's my even more least
favorite question what you just said
because I don't have an answer for it I
don't know what this is gonna be what's
your favorite episode of good mythical
morning Oh your favorite episode again
that's when I always answer you know to
be honest with you they all kind of run
together I mean like people who watch
the show remember the show better than
we do and remember specific details of
the show better than we do but I did
recently answer that question that just
because it just seemed like a good
answer at the time that the post Malone
I said a hip itsy-bitsy spider went down
the water spin spout because it seemed
like a good answer because again I don't
really know it's like I there's a
there's a lot of as those that I liked
had a blast doing always so the next one
but post Malone that was one that is
super it may be the most memorable one
the one that makes me feel the coolest
yeah but we were we were kind of
stressed out it's like you know you we
you know it was a stressful environment
with that the musical exercise we were
doing so it was like yeah I was rather
in front of post Malone rapping like
post Malone in front of postman at the
time little nerve-racking I would say so
I don't know it wasn't but but as an
episode but maybe not as an experience
at the time
here we go editing questions that we're
tired of got any other ones you want to
let's move on this is a question how
tall are you
before we move on I'm just curious oh oh
no one's ever asked that thanks for
asking
oh how tall I 5:19 see it you came out
you have the cute answer it's like what
the question to get all the time you
should have a cutie instead of just move
on and that's why we hate those other
two because we don't have a cute answer
let's come up with cute answer so this
believe it or not it's a question that
we're asked a lot might as well answer
it this is from ally Dickinson this is
it just came from two different people
in two different ways ally Dickinson
asked what is the one thing you would
tell young rhettandlink if given the
chance and EMA softened better on
Twitter asked if you were given the
opportunity to go back and change one
thing in your lives would you could be a
correction of a mistake or skipping
skipping out on something you knew ended
horribly or would you be too afraid of
the dreaded butterfly effect
so so this this type of question if you
could go back blah blah blah is when
we're tired of being asked well I think
people ask that because our history our
shared history is such a part of the
work that we do and we're talking all
the time about our past and so and then
we also say things like who would have
known that going to engineering school
would have led to this and actually I
think people isn't it's natural to be
like well what would you do would you go
would you say something to young
rhettandlink and what would it be and
would you be afraid to screw things up I
actually have a brand new answer to this
like I was I was literally thinking
about this yesterday okay so I have an
answer yeah do you have an answer uh
well I actually kind of have a brand-new
I have a the same old answer in a brand
new way do you want to go first
because I was talking I was talking with
my you know you answer your answer first
while I was at the gym and I was
thinking
that my shoulders started hurting again
hold on you're joking that you started
think I'm at the gym no I I was at the
gym and my shoulders started hurting and
it this is related to my shoulder okay
this is kind of freaky you'll see why
this again is this the butterfly effect
why your eyes getting so wide as a
butterfly about to come out of them
because it's weird that independently
you went to a very similar place that
I'm about to go but just go ahead the
gym yes really literally the gym is
where and and it was literally yesterday
what yesterday morning yesterday morning
we have been what exploring this
question at the same time what if I
could you see a butterfly come through
if I could if I could go back in time I
wouldn't have thought about it
it's too weird this is way too weird and
not only did my happen at the gym but it
was in relationship to an injury I think
this just says that we're like old and
decrepit but I'll go nope but it's weird
and like yeah in you know like our lives
there and didn't need to mirror each
other man I was looking in the mirror
too I was um while I was doing some
pull-ups and then he stopped I'm
freaking out I mean by the time this
comes out this video is long gone off
the wave of the Internet but this it was
that um the guy in Switzerland who was
hang gliding wig oh gosh
in tandem with a with a hang gliding
guide and the guy didn't strap in strap
him in so his like pelvis was like
hanging up and being supported by the
weight of a strap and the entire ride
from the top of a mountain in
Switzerland the dude is hanging on
sometimes by hit only his left hand for
dear life as the guy tries to steer down
the side of the mountain and he and the
guy who trains me is like showing me
this footage and then he's like it's
crazy he doesn't die which makes it fun
to talk about he seems to have a good
sense of humor about it but he
torez bicep and he was he tore his bicep
and he he hurt his shoulder and then
first of all crazy and we said he was
able to hold on that long yep and to
hurt himself that badly
cuz to nago my trainer guy he was like
there's this there's this challenge
where I can't remember we said it was
hang glider challenge now all youtubers
are Julian he was like if you hold on to
its the it's at Venice Beach you can go
there and if you can hold on for a
hundred seconds you'll give you a
hundred dollars
just hang just hang for a hundred
seconds
it'd be a lot harder than it seems and
then he's like how let's see how long
you can hang now I had already done some
pull-ups okay you know full unseated
pull-ups like lock elbow back up but I
thought that hanging was supposed to
make shoulders feel good I'm just saying
that I was a little tired and then I
started hanging okay and he starts
timing me how long do you think I went
well if a hundred seconds gives you a
hundred dollars it means that in order
to make that a profitable proposition no
more than 5% of people could do it I
would put you in the 40th percentile
thanks after my pull-ups right I put you
in the 30th percentile after pull-ups so
I think he went for 27 seconds uh thanks
for that vote of confidence
I went 45 seconds oh okay not bad but
that was really hard but you know my
life wasn't in danger
I wasn't literally hovering over the
Alps or wherever they were it was really
hard mm-hmm that's all I could do
I bet you I couldn't do that I bet you I
couldn't dude 40 so then afterward I was
like my shoulder was already that didn't
make my shoulder hurt my shoulder was
already hurt him from doing some
kettlebell swings a week earlier and I
was I was kind of and then so like doing
something like having fun doing this
hanging challenge is something that like
I started getting nervous about and then
I started thinking you were having fun I
was having fun at the gym well and but I
was like I'm nervous that my shoulder is
gonna be hurt worse and then I'm like
you know what if
I could go back in time I would go back
I guess it would be four years ago now
and I would not sleep on my right arm if
you take I would sleep on my right side
and I would put my hand behind my neck
so as to be resting my right ear and
thereby my entire head on my right arm
and I would just lay there like that and
sleep and which would allow me to spoon
Christy okay I'm just I'm just saying
you know you wanna you want to get
snuggly I can't sleep in the
configuration well I did it for at least
four years I did it for a year I will
say though that your your shoulder issue
it was a college thing as well I
remember do it like on the bench press
it was sometimes up it popped out yeah
it was kind of it started pretty early
what my physical therapist cuz I went to
physical therapy this is what actually
ironically got me to start going to the
gym consistently was on the on the
backside of going to I went to the
doctor for my shoulder he sent me to
physical therapy which made the pain go
away
but what they just what they explained
in physical therapy was you need to keep
doing these exercises forever and so
then I started going to the gym till you
die but they also he also explained that
like the way that I would put my arm up
like that it's basically like if you
were to raise your hand right now and
then picture the the two bones coming
together in your shoulder and rubbing
against each other and then being in
traction and after that grinding mmm it
just it wore down the the cartilage and
cushiony stuff and now that stuff
doesn't grow back so now if I don't get
if I don't stem cells man look at me I
know but you can go to Panama and get in
jail I do that it's so frustrating that
if I just slept on my back and not
cultivated this habit of sleeping on my
right side I wouldn't have this this
pain now now let me interject it this
and so that is the thing that I would do
let me interject at this point I'm done
you're not interjected
before you you say that you would but I
want to talk about whether you actually
would or not because I was at the gym
and I was what doing the deadlift which
first of all for me I'm only at the gym
at the gym because I want to be in shape
and not just turn into just a ball of
jelly but I am also primarily the things
that I do at the gym are intended to
strengthen my back and let me just say
right now my back is in better shape
than it has been probably in like since
college maybe since high school like it
is in really good shape we could all
fall apart at any moment if I twist the
wrong way but it's a lot stronger and so
my trainer has been like working on
introducing more exercises and of course
the deadlift is something that you could
get really wrong really easily and it
gives a lot of damage yeah and as I was
doing it and I don't put hardly any
weight on there it's just like it's the
rack and then like a wheel on each side
so like like a hundred pounds or
something it's like it's just basically
to just get the motion right I'm not
doing a lot okay but I was like no
embarrassing it was like you know in
high school still I'm a trainer I would
put three wheels on each side I don't
know how much that is
and it harness central high school at
the time weightlifting class wasn't like
well how are you supposed to do this it
was just like they put three wheels on
each side of the deadlift bar and then
guys would just line up one by one and
see if they could lift it I'm not saying
it wasn't it was more of a contest it
was like can you do it can you do it and
I would look at myself in the mirror
even though I was wearing a weight belt
I don't wear a weight belt now cuz you
if you're doing it right you shouldn't
need one and I yeah would be bending
over and putting all the weight on my
lower back and just like bending like
that and you know what that's what
created my back problems I there's a
couple other weird injuries but I feel
like that was the start of the real bad
like herniation xand sort of changed the
way the
I in fact I was telling her I was like
you kind of changed the way I played
basketball my senior season because I
like my back was messed up and and then
I was like you know if I could go back I
would run intended I wouldn't have done
that and I wish I could go back and tell
my younger self like you realize that
that's stupid if you could like it
yourself if you did this right and you
did it with less weight and you got the
form right like you could actually like
make yourself a better athlete like you
could jump higher not from doing calf
raises like we were stupid we thought
they the way to jump higher was to do
calf raises like yeah your calves are
can contribute to your vertical leap a
very very small amount
it's your glutes man it's your legs is
this your upper ttle it's your upper
legs and so I was like man I you know I
got recruited by some colleges I was
like if I could go back in like two I
would probably have been recruited by
some bigger schools and then I was like
but you know what I wouldn't go back and
do that because if I had a gone and
played college basketball I probably
wouldn't be here right now see but
that's a different woman she was like
yeah you'd be somewhere in Wisconsin you
know what that and that'd be sad so I
wanna go back man I'm glad you mucked up
your back man but for me I'm only
talking like going back doesn't matter
I'm sleeping on my back how could that
butterfly affect anything it would
affect every do you think Chrissy and I
would be divorced now because I didn't
spoon her for that year you would be
divorced remarried you'd have a little
kid named Linc jr. every well that's
been weird because I'm the third I know
that's how weird it would be did he'd
have a link jr. I have my dad yeah and
it's your whole life would be different
if you slept on your back five years ago
I everything would be different I'll
believe in the butterfly effect when it
applies to sleeping position and I just
want to stop and tell all of you now you
do not sleep don't sleep with a
contorted arm use common sense and
sleeping on your back is great for your
sleep on your back no matter what it's
great for everything except spooning I
think it does something to your face
I think it does it like stretches your
face or something stretches your face I
don't know maybe it does okay we we
certainly spend a lot of time on that
question that we didn't want to end like
Jack Burch asks Thank You Emma and Allie
if you could place yourself in any
fictional universe or movie which would
you pick and why oh okay just knee-jerk
response to this for me is middle-earth
man I mean but and I thought
specifically like where the Wood Elves
lived they're the ones that I haven't
watched it in a long time but they're
the ones who I believe came out of it
was um they were more mysterious in the
woods they were the ones that didn't
make the trek to the new land and they
just kind of hunkered down where they
ended up and I think they played more
into the Hobbit stories which
chronologically came earlier but then
it's not the middle-earth that is so
special to me from them well there's a
got toriel and I'm which she's not even
in the books
I do like Evangeline whatever and Lily
though do you like her really yeah I
watched the first half of Ant Man 2 on
the plane well I'm into the second half
oh well the plane landed you got a time
it better than that I never was like
that time you're knocking twist you get
a time your plane movies you got a look
at the flight time do the math it's kind
of I kind of think in my brain it's like
the Ewok village so I guess what I'm
really saying is I'd like to live in the
Ewok village if that were within
middle-earth with elves because it's
hard to communicate with those Ewoks but
the elves are like you know they speak
calmly and good warriors here's the
thing you would be in you can't pick a
place because I would be like I'd like
to live in Rivendell but this is the
entire fictional universe this is the
entire movie the tight the entire world
there and I honest that probably end up
in Hobbiton just eating and gardening
that's a great answer thank you right I
actually disagree with it though and
this is gonna be controversial and it
actually leads into another question
that we were asked okay because I feel
like I had to have a lot of qualifiers
here because I as opposed
to middle-earth would pick Narnia okay
and the reason I would pick Narnia is
because I think ultimately it's more fun
and more rewarding and much less what do
you mean more danger what do you mean
more fun let's start there cuz the evil
middle-earth is very evil evil in Narnia
is significantly less threatening than
the evil in middle-earth so you're
living in a kid's world but what you're
really saying but I also think that
Narnia the thing that always intrigued
me about those books and they kind of
remain like my favorite even though
clearly the Fellowship of the Ring is a
better series but it's for it's not for
kids it's it's more a young adult an
adult whereas Narnia is clearly for
young kids you know but I enjoyed it
first as like a single-digit age I don't
know what I was but the first time I
read them and the accessibility but also
the way they related the real world to
the imaginative world of Narnia and the
ability to like there is a wardrobe that
you can go through like there's a play
there are these places that you could
enter into the world so it created this
I met I had this imagination
I would always I would be had an
imagination I would be out in the woods
it's cool and I would see like a tree
with like a hole you like the portal and
I was like okay maybe this is the Narnia
like maybe this is the time maybe this
is I'm gonna go up to this and I'm gonna
stick my head into this hole in this
tree well that's how you exit Narnia you
should've been looking for a wardrobe no
no but there's more you can get in there
multiple deep ways and I figured that in
my world okay not England but the u.s.
modern day maybe there were other ways
into Narnia but I feel like to the
generation of let's just say the
Millennials
I feel like Narnia has been soiled
because the movies pretty much sucked oh
so I think when they when they think
about Narnia they think about the movie
okay okay that's why I would go into
this other question Kevin Mata asks if
you were given the opportunity to remake
a movie which would you choose
okay so first of all see Narnia I didn't
read the books so if you're judging it
off of the movies then you're like no
contest there's no contest between I
wish I could go back to my childhood and
read those books okay I'm just I just
wanted to say that well I keep I there's
a lot of reasons go back now that I
think about it you're gonna screw
everything if you go back every Narnia
so I'm you're saying I don't have that I
don't I didn't have an expectation I
also my kids weren't of an age to take
them and they didn't care so I actually
didn't end up watching them in the
theater but they I did watch one and it
did kind of suck it okay he's probably
too strong of a word I know some of you
may have really liked the movies but it
was in terms of how impactful the books
were for me personally but I think first
of all there's you age it up because
that wouldn't be true to the books and I
think that's really what you're saying
that was your that's your critique of it
is it that no there there are movies
that are more intended for kids that
capture there was a cheesiness to the to
the movies that also something that for
some reason didn't seem to happen with
Lord of the Rings like it was a weird
moment in CGI technology yep not quite
as weird as like five years before that
mm-hmm but just something about the way
that you have this you have this view of
Aslan and what he's going to mean to you
you know that and then you see him
you're like that's just Liam Neeson and
also it sounds like Liam Neeson is in my
freaking ear because he just did this
voice over into like a microphone like
this I think we're talking budget I
think there may have budget issues I
think they spent a lot of money they
spent what was the budget on the the
Narnia movies and and then what was the
budget on the Lord of the Rings can you
just look those out real quick but
they're doing and then we're gonna see
we're doing on Peter Jackson who I don't
know who directed The Chronicles of
Narnia
Disney is doing these like I should do
the next one live-action remakes like
you know like The Lion King is a lot of
people like really excited about that
you know but thank you all three thank
you pitching a remake that is like that
five hundred sixty million for how many
movies three that's a lot of money man I
made a lot of money one point successful
because of the Ip Man yeah but what
about Lord of the Rings 291 total they
don't shoot in the US but they made more
money they made more than 1.6 billion
two point nine billion so two almost
twice as much that's irrelevant to your
point anyway because here's the thing
that I wouldn't do a lot of people like
just a couple of weeks ago on Twitter
people were talking about like are they
gonna remake Back to the Future and a
lot of people wisely said no don't you
don't remake movies that were perfect
you don't remake perfect movies unless
you're a freaking idiot so that's why I
I think you're onto something you make
narni rebate movies that sucked
that well that didn't that didn't they
weren't as magical as they needed to be
and and they can benefit from technology
now like the way that Disney's remaking
these movies I mean people are
critiquing the trailer and saying that
The Lion King is like a shot-for-shot it
seems like and it's like is that really
necessary I mean okay well hold on this
might be an exception because remaking
the Lion King in a different way is a
slightly different conversation but what
are you gonna do with Back to the Future
you're gonna make another live-action
back to the future no you make it
animated with Legos Lego can do that
okay let go if it translates let go back
to the future the only way to accept
ibly remake a movie that was done well
the first time is to change the medium
that's the rule okay so you can go to
animation from live-action which is
weird
you can go definitely go
action from animation which is cool
because it's been done Jungle Book was
that good I don't know yeah it was good
there was a live-action character in
that though and there's not one in the
Lion King yeah I was like I don't lovers
in it and I was like no he's not his
voice isn't it it's different guys I
haven't seen enough movies to know what
to remake it so let's ask another
question okay every movie that I've seen
I only see movies if they like if
they're fresh on Rotten Tomatoes and the
audience likes them and I you know what
I don't see a lot of movies right yeah
you don't like Rotten Tomatoes reviews
you don't think they're reliable you
don't get both those together yeah I
don't watch a lot of movies in the
theater all right I ain't got time for
that
they got it's got to be a knock it out
of the park type situation uh Madison
right asks I'm gonna remake Aquaman like
I want to do a low-budget I'll be
Aquaman hmm I can't hold my breath that
long we actually we heard an interesting
sort of industry story about Aquaman
that I wanted to tell huh and but i'ma
go ahead and my wife's my wife's
favorite person who's not me
Jason Momoa now here's a something that
we heard this this is inside industry
knowledge we we know someone who knows
someone who worked in some costume
design on Aquaman and they spent all
this time creating this amazing yeah
Aquaman made Aquaman suit that was like
had the scale I don't know what do I
haven't seen it I'm not gonna scales and
they were like made out of something and
like it was they spent like months like
working on this thing and like
handcrafting it and then they like gave
it to Jason Momoa and he liked because
it was like it's too heavy
and so they ended up like painting
painting his stuff on him
yeah so take that which we've done that
Jessie that's what Jason Momoa will do
for you yo you'll work on his suit for
months and then you just give it to him
and he's like too heavy but he looks but
he looks great just having paint on him
so she knows that right I shouldn't even
say his name that just puts him in her
mind I'm actually thinking about seeing
that move in she looks at me right oh
yeah right the gym man I mean I'm gonna
be Jason Momoa and about okay no you're
not nine months okay you you want it
think about that a little bit or do you
want me to move on uh yeah let's go with
Erickson here oh you want to go there no
we'll go back let's go back we'll get to
everybody Madison where are we read it I
gave birth to a pineapple on your tour
in Portland right are you ever going to
start sending me fruit child support or
do I need to bring in my mom's cousin's
daughter who's a lawyer slash opera
singer this is Madison who is it was
incredibly memorable and actually was
the first person to give birth to the
pineapple
well we didn't you know it's just
someone on stage who's supposed to model
the pineapple we didn't say that she had
we did not plan no it was a it was an
impromptu interaction that led to her
simulating childbirth with a pineapple
but to answer your question I don't
think we have to send fruit oh no we are
not in California we're not gonna send
you fruit child support hmm
yes you need to bring in your mom's
cousins daughter who's a lawyer slash
opera singer I'd like I'd like to get
litigated via opera bring it on girl but
Madison can you dress his Aquaman yeah
there's a suit available it's very heavy
though Madison was very memorable and I
think we were I remember after she did
that she sat back down and I remember
saying something like we might have an
opening a mythical entertainment for you
because she was so funny in the moment
so really that's what she should have
asked is you know where do I send my
resume
but she didn't she chose to threaten
litigation and look at her now belittled
in a podcast now we can get to Erickson
because I didn't want a good Raley
Erickson asks do you think cannibalism
would solve world hunger and population
control oh gosh that is a morbid thought
readily if people ate each other they
would I mean they would not be as hungry
true that's true and then the people who
they ate I assume who died well this it
because there's two there's three forms
of cannibalism okay and I don't know the
technical terms the first form is like
the movie alive about the soccer team
that gets stranded in the Alps mm-hmm
that is eating your friends after
they've already died that is a form of
cannibalism you know in order to survive
yes and in my mind that is acceptable
second form of cannibalism is killing
and consuming someone in my mind that is
not acceptable that's murder
and the third form of cannibalism is
voluntary non fatal cat cannibalism
where you cut off part of your body and
feed it to a group of people but don't
die you know this is this is the most
interesting form of cannibalism in my
mind
well let's camp out here shall we okay
so you're safe so you're slicing off
your like you're like at a wedding
reception you're like got your leg up on
the table like a ham hock yeah like a
like a prime rib you're just slicing
your oh god well it was it would have
been surgically removed in a sterile
environment you would be okay and then
you would present it and you'd be like
this week no okay we all don't die we're
eating my leg now let's not nice look
whether you eat your own self no I don't
you wouldn't know I haven't thought that
you wouldn't remove your whole leg you
would just remove like a calf muscle
like I was part of your jerky you would
be like a
you'd remove part of the muscle that
would then regenerate like a lizard's
tail muscle doesn't regenerate in that
way but you can't build it up and maybe
get close to this demands right it
doesn't regenerate but you can that
that's why it is a it's not a renewable
resource so that's why this is a bad I
mean I got gluts for days I've been
doing lots of deadlifts so I feel like I
could take you could take a scoop of my
glute out and be like its glute scoops
tonight but I do think we should we
should we should glute scoops that's not
gonna work those meatballs know they're
glute scoops it's not gonna work hold on
why don't you think this is gonna work
because it's not renewable but farming
lizards and then removing their tails
for consumption could help with global
impoverishment hunger but what kind of
nutritional value is there in lizard
tails and some enough I don't I'm sure
you can I'm sure we can we can breed a
me detailed lizard and then you're just
scaring it and it loses its tail and
then it regenerates and you just it's
like Christmas trees you have a whole
bunch of them and then they're in stages
so it's like this this group of
free-range happy lizards okay light
union Lhasa and they're out there
roaming around but it's like you know
they're they're bred for their me
details and they're at different stages
this pasture over here of lizards is you
know they they got some I got some fully
developed tails we're about to yes we're
about to scare us like a crop yeah and
then all you do is you just run through
the pasture and a ripe peach you lose
their tails that's a pretty good idea I
don't know if it's a good idea this is
like Elan musk situation man I should be
talking to him not you
i I think that lizard tails are probably
not as good of an idea as just farming
insects because far farming insects but
but that kills the insects if you don't
want to kill the insect then you got to
go with lizards they're donating their
tails which is kind of what you
with the glute scoops I was just trying
to go with your vibe here but if you
want to go back to cannibalism I really
think we have to talk about eating dead
people I mean just across the board well
first of all I'm not an expert on this
but it is my understanding that eating
dead people is not good for humans the
people who are doing the eating I think
that's unhealthy what I mean it I more
so more so than just eating meat they
died from you know but usually if you
could survive even if it's prepared well
on a mountain for like you could survive
but you're saying it's not good for you
or you it's not gonna kill you
I see not attrition I seem to have read
at some point that people eating people
leads to weird diseases maybe I'm wrong
about that I that doesn't ring true to
me I mean isn't isn't it isn't like a
glute scoop from it from a freshly dead
person who say you know what I want to
donate my glutes to be scooped for you
know to feed the world I don't know just
something about it just seems like it
would go bad after well if you have all
your eating is gluts coops for days on
end well I'm not saying it's all you eat
I'm not I'm not trying to say that but
muscle is a balanced diet I'm just
saying it's a it's a part of a balanced
diet but but yeah technically he was at
Raley which I like that name by the way
Raley Eriksson so like that maybe
Eriksson it doesn't like anybody to
scoop your gluts when you die it sounds
like someone who might honestly might
commit a murder this week Raley Eriksson
arrested for cannibalism in an effort to
contribute to population control and
solve world hunger sorry I don't know
it's a beautiful name I don't I don't I
think it's a good idea to eat fresh
consensual dead people consensual I
don't know man I don't know I think if I
get your cure
is what it tastes like well I know it
was what well I already said that if if
I had to I would without qualms eat a
person for survival like that but I
wouldn't make it a part of my diet but
there is an interesting proposition that
if for some reason it doesn't turn out
to be bad for you if we could just take
all the dead people and create a slurry
out of them Oh God like Soylent Green
what right I mean that's Soylent Green
is people spoiler alert but seriously I
mean like you could potentially create a
Soylent from human from dead human
tissue and if it was but I don't like to
eat meat slurry I like to eat I like to
eat like cuts of meat it would have
additives in it that would make it taste
okay okay fine let me do it it seems to
it seems to be better than you know just
let him rot I'm burning them I don't
think I de I don't think it's an
abomination I mean it sounds like it
should be but I don't think it
technically is I don't know what that
means I think I don't know if you can
determine what an abomination is that's
true on a personal level maybe it's not
an abomination well I think you can
because if it's not about it's
definitely an abomination to some people
okay right but I would do it like I said
you want you want to move all because
yeah Pete sure ideon nice just share it
okay Pete share didn't ask you know Pete
you should bring about you've been in LA
too long
yeah all you got to do is that one more
I Pete shared and you got you got you're
onto something you and Rayleigh Erikson
can eat dead people together Pete sure
ideon and Rayleigh Erikson the serial
killing duo glute scooping across
America who knew that when you ask a
question on the social media that we
were gonna make you into cannibalistic
serial killing duo yeah be careful be
careful let you ask dressed as Aquaman
Pete Sheridan asks do you guys know what
this
- on my leg is well first of all Pete
you didn't send a picture
second of all Pete don't send a picture
I don't I don't know how to identify
rashes on legs but I wonder if that
impacts the viability of the meat of the
leg you definitely do not want meat that
has been banished in hydrocortisone
cream or just or not it just has a rash
yeah well no I just peel the skin off it
is a rash go to the muscle if the rash
goes to the muscle Pete you need to see
a doctor Emil because that's not a rash
well like kinda like an apple gets
rotten it starts on the skin it's a
little different yeah that would be
gangrene that's not a rash don't eat
don't eat the mushy parts if the glute
scoops mushy now move on speaking of
good names
Magnus Mar Payson getting a closer look
Magnus Marv Paulson okay which is
definitely some sort of Scandinavian
name I would think right I get who are
we to generalize I get a lot of ideas
and inspiration from you guys Wow well
thank you from watching new GM's and
your biscuits as well as just watching
old rhettandlink music videos and old
GMM videos back when you guys started I
wanted to know what content creators
musicians and authors etc inspire you
guys that's a good question MMP now
first of all this question makes me a
little bit I feel a little inadequate
whenever I think about this and
definitely when I'm asked it here's
here's why okay
whenever you see like a respected
artists interviewed talk about their
work it seems like the references their
influences and references to other works
are like right on the tip of their
tongue like
and I've always felt a little funny
about that because sure me and you are
heavily have been heavily influenced by
a lot of people and a lot of forms of
entertainment but we haven't processed
it very directly right sometimes people
that what did you guys think was funny
growing up and I'll be like my dad which
is which is is has influenced the way
that I make the funny but also like me
and you we watched we were big fans of
Seinfeld we watched Seinfeld in high
school we watched
SNL growing up and we would bond over
the latest like Jack Handey deep
thoughts you know and yeah Lorne
Michaels is famous for saying that
people usually say that their favorite
era SNL is when they were in high school
for us I think it may have been when we
were middle school is when we were like
really connecting with it yeah but
anyway sure there's lots of like sort of
traditional things that were influenced
by but it it's not this very direct it's
not like we are just guys like you we're
not film makers right you know we hope
to make movies we have made a
documentary but we haven't made a
scripted and narrative film yet but when
we sit down to do that it's not like
we're a film director who's like well
these are my favorite visual influences
these are the DPS that I like these are
the directors that I like this is the it
this is the style that I that I like and
this is the way that I'm going to kind
of take these pieces and then create my
derivative yet original approach to this
thing hmm and it's just not that's not
how we we don't think that way directly
I think it we think that way it is sort
of inherently actually I have a list oh
good go for it take your list just
joking yeah I I related that but I I did
come up with somebody and I do think if
we if we NER if we look at a particular
medium and then we really think about it
we
say who inspired us okay so if you think
about music or if you think about our
favorite films or our favorite
television shows we can we can trace or
the Internet we can trace the things
that inspire us to be creative it just
requires a little work that maybe we
haven't done but an answer did come to
my mind which is related to what I'm
saying that the fact that we have
aspirations in so many of these
different genres like you know we want a
music live performance movies television
internet what books but we want to do
all these things like even it's just
exciting to to be creative in all the
different mediums which means that which
made me think that I'm really inspired
by Donald Glover because of the way that
he's done all of those things and
refused to really be identify
pigeon-holed as any particular yeah like
any particular genre or medium I mean
that last album is one of my favorites
you know I can pick out his musical
influences the most recent or the
previous awaken my love which is I mean
he's only released singles yeah just
like this you know and then the way that
Atlanta is so it's so creative and it's
a comedy but it's so many so many more
things than that and each episode is an
opportunity to reinvent what the show is
you know there's lots of it's just I
love the way he approaches his live
shows and I've you know he makes him so
special for the people who go there and
there's their events they're not just a
concert and he just has that mentality
he's working on some movie with Rihanna
yeah jealous much that's Briggs firing
yeah and you know what that man talent
he was I have an idea to do this type of
thing in this monitor 11
well a lot of people don't know well you
probably know if you're listening to
this but he start he's starting on
YouTube he was right and Derek comedy
which I don't I guess that channel still
exists but this him and some of his
friends this making sketches mm-hmm you
know some people who were back making
sketches on YouTube back in the day are
still on YouTube other people are donald
glover but he we have a tremendous
opportunity given the the way that we've
been successful to then say hey we do
want to write a book or we do want to do
a stage show and then we can actually do
it you know so i'm very much inspired by
the by the the the creative terms with
which he goes into something and the way
that he brings his fans along with him i
may have talked about that before so i
mean that's always inspiring so I think
that's my that's my answer
that's alright now that's a good answer
if I could go back in time I'd probably
come up with even well but the
interesting thing is that you're
inspired by him in a similar way that
now I'm thinking of some someone who
inspires me in a similar way but it
again it's it's not as direct of an
inspiration so in other words we want to
do a lot of things we want to do them
all in an excellent way and Donald
Glover is this sort of impossible
standard that we can always sort of
aspire to and never reach but hopefully
get better as we as we try to but
there's nothing in particular about any
of the stuff that he does which is going
to be like we're not gonna make like a
funk album whatever you know by the way
did I tell you unless you want to did we
tell him that we that I met him yeah we
I think we told the story about meeting
him at a local a local place I
personally thought that's gonna round a
part you should have gone up to him with
your son Lando and said my son's name is
Lando can I get a picture with you and
it would've been like a cool a really
cool thing I didn't I didn't needed to
be for anybody else but me but I didn't
need to share it with but as we've
established before you went up to john c
reilly while he was eating with his
friends in a restaurant
that was that was so you're not you're
not above going up to celebrities well
I've changed but again so but it's not
specific works but somebody who's career
inspires me and is inspiring me right
now because I tend to be like influenced
by things as I'm kind of exploring them
the Duplass brothers Mark and Jay
Duplass they've got a book that I'm
listening to it's like a short audio
book it's like seven hours and it's
called like brothers but they are
brothers and they are brothers
interesting isn't it
now the thing I wouldn't have said that
like I I haven't seen all their movies
and I wouldn't say that like I'm a
student of the Duplass brothers films
I'm obviously very familiar with them
and kind of know a little bit about
their story and like the independent
film situation and puffy chair and
Sundance and all that stuff so I'm
always like I had this respect and I and
I've always I've always kind of known
that I think there are about our age or
a little bit older and I think well
reading this book it's been kind of
weird
in one sense because it's two guys from
the south with a with a weird obsession
with Lionel Richie really who both the
way they divide their work up in terms
of light one's kind of the starter and
one's kind of the finisher it's and
that's just to name a few things there
was some other sort of like in their
book like their wives read one chapter
like it really yeah yeah and then they
their book is sort of like a compendium
of unsolicited advice but they actually
had the wherewithal to use the term
unsolicited advice when they gave it we
just gave it and then like stories from
their past and their and how their
relationship works and that kind of
thing is the way they communicate anyway
I told you that you should be listening
to it you should at some point you
should be listening to it as well why
are you listening to this you should go
listen to that do Plus brothers book but
anyway the thing that was routes super
inspiring about them
just this you listen to somebody's story
about I think the thing that they sort
of represent is sticking to artistic
intention mm-hm and not compromising not
compromising too much because the other
thing that they are is they're not like
and they say multiple times in the book
but they're not these very precious like
artists who have this vision that cannot
be compromised they they know they're
practical they have a practical to come
from a very like that's like this
logical place where you know they know
how to work with people and they know
how to try to get their vision but also
do it in a practical way that like
satisfies like a studio that they may be
working with or whatever but anyway it
just got me I got super inspired to what
or was it to what or just not well we're
always thinking and doing things again
I've said I feel like I say this a lot
on your biscuits we're always thinking
about and working on things that we
can't talk about but I think that some
of the some of the things that they
talked about in terms of like
establishing it let's put it this way it
made me feel really good about some
things that we're working on in terms of
like things that kind of pull from your
personal experience
they use the term mining the epic
smallness of your own life which is the
idea that you have a very particular
perspective and background and you kind
of get in the middle of it you get too
close of it and you can kind of discount
oh we shouldn't be telling this person's
story we should be telling our story now
they tell a bunch of different stories
but they're always telling it kind of
through the perspective of what they
know and how they see the world and I
always get excited about telling stories
and what we're going to do with that as
our career advances so anyway well
that's a good book or recommendation
yeah yeah they're there and I hope we
can we we can we can meet him and like
hang out with Lionel Richie all five of
us together it'll be wonderful
wonderful
quintuple date are they obsessed with
the pose because that would be a little
too close there's no reference to the
pose okay but well and I hear they had a
band together so of course they were a
band together and they sing Lionel
covers which I actually don't think we
ever sing a Lionel cover
mmm that would not different we were too
cool for that
no we just weren't good enough well that
brings our AMA to a close but you know
what I think we have one more answer you
inspire us oh yes boy is nothing
something quite as inspiring as giving
us attention so thanks for doing that I
you know I for the we've heard that
we've been an inspiration to to people
and boy that's uh that is really nice
yeah I actually was really nice to find
out that you inspired somebody I was I
was looking through as I do from time to
time looking for reviews of our book of
mythicality I do that from time to time
for self validation and I read I came
across a review that was somebody gave
us two stars two stars out of five and
then said if these guys were half as
interesting as they think they are this
would be a good book and so yeah I'm
glad you brought that up yeah we think
we're pretty interesting I don't I don't
know what to say to that you're not
really supposed to I just thought it was
funny but you know you should do you
know what else is interesting you should
go to youtube.com slash your biscuits
it's a new YouTube channel you can
subscribe to it now there's nothing
there but there will be soon including
zero subscribers
we're not I thought we're repurposing a
channel yeah yeah okay well we have a
little bit we have a little bit of a
head start but Twelver there are
thousands and subscribe to youtube [ __ ]
comm plus your business and all your
favorite ear biscuits from the past
present and the future will be there if
you want to talk about cannibalism
hashtag ear biscuits let's go for it
let's do it mmm we'll talk about you
next week is this year grinds to a halt
just like my shoulder was grinding
against itself for years man if I could
just go back to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best